80 judokas de l'équipe de france sur les
tatamis du creps de bourges seulement
quelques jours après les jumeaux tokyo
c'est un nouveau départ pour certaines
c'est l'occasion
de relancer la machine avec des filles
un peu plus jeunes qui sont présentes en
sachant que les seniors qui était aux
jeux olympiques et qui était aussi
réserves sont pas là sont au repos donc
là on va chercher un peu plus dans le
réservoir pour
dans l'objectif de préparer les paris
2024 le monde du sport est déjà reparti
avec des championnats d'europe de judo à
la rentrée et une saison que tous
espèrent plein et surtout sans convient
de jacoby de ça nous a un peu pas
malgache et l'année sur certaines
compétitions et du coup bah fallait
quand même resté dedans et du coup ce
stage il permet de mieux se préparer de
de refaire le point et de repartir sur
une nouvelle saison qui sera j'espère
mieux que cette année le stage dure une
dizaine de jours remettre le pied au
tatami mais pas que faire revivre les
structures sportives qui en ont bien
besoin les activités fédérales les
activités sportives régionales locales
vraiment redémarre et donc d'accueillir
aujourd'hui en plus là pour une grosse
semaine l'équipe de france de judo c'est
pour nous aussi un nouveau départ départ
qui va enchaîner avec tout le reste de
la rentrée avec un certain nombre
d'accueil
voilà jusqu'au au moins la fin d'année
début d'année prochaine une année
sportive qui redémarre en même temps que
des incertitudes liées à la pandémie